[Music]  they really gotta marry this guy I don't  even know I think anyone that's Mariah  Carey's now boyfriend Bryan Tanaka  confronting her about then fiance James  Packer in the new promo clip for Sunday  season finale of Mariah's world it's  clear tanaka wants answers I think you  have a different set of issues than me  it's want you to be happy  sometimes many people aren't supposed to  be happy make me smile  not only is Tanaka winning in his  personal life he's also doing well  professionally watch what happens when  Mariah's creative director Anthony  Burrell learns about Tanaka's unexpected  promotion I'm absolutely not happy about  this I don't need a co-creative director  did you were to knock back from ten  years ago it's not anything other than  like like what it's really gonna work  for me  [Music]  you